this show is brought to you by onit.com
go to onit.com and use codeword church
to get 10 off of all their optimization
products like alpha brand new mood swim
tech immune shroom tech sport it's
codeboard church to get ten percent back
go to hit ecigs.com better tasting
longer lasting the proof is in the vape
if you're looking to quit smoking in the
new year they have e-cigarettes and
e-cigars for you at different levels of
nicotine and hopefully eventually you'll
get down to zero if that's what you're
looking to do use codeword joey's church
to get twenty percent off
go to
irondragontv.com and use go where joey
to get two free rentals
of all their martial arts movies it's a
new roku channel
has all of all the favorite martial arts
movies
jackie chan a lot of the old stuff
a lot of cool movies to cover joey and
go to nailed it live dot com
and you go over joey diaz
to get uh twenty percent off of the
premier vapor pen on the market for all
the oil and wax smokers out there what'd
you give me in those stars what's in
those [ __ ] stars you put a label over
another label
did you put a label over another there's
no label on anything he gets
the guy doesn't even work at the weed
storage
there's some guy rolling my brownies
i love you [ __ ] the church of what's
happening now
monday
january 19th you bad [ __ ] take
that shitley that's the [ __ ]
beatles baby
oh [ __ ]
this is the first album no no this was
later what was this reinvention sergeant
pepper's lonely hearts club band what
was that supposed to be about i have no
[ __ ] idea it was so long ago but the
cover is tremendous yeah so much in
there the cover is tremendous they got
the flowers and the shape of the guitar
and it says paul's dead oh it says that
remember they played the whole trick in
the united states that paul mccartney
was dead these [ __ ] saps fell for it
but it was tremendous marketing yeah
they didn't know at the time that was
the most brilliant marketing they had
ever [ __ ] read they played iron the
walrus backwards says all that crazy i
just started getting vinyls and a couple
of them had really cool like artwork and
then i got a steve martin one that had a
set list in the on the back it was
pretty cool i never had anybody set this
that's a cool thing to put on here it
was a photocopied setlist on like a car
on the back of like a cardboard uh
headshot
it was pretty cool yeah i someone got me
one and it's like kind of a thing now
they like to get back in the vinyl but
somebody got me a vinyl so i gotta get
you bill cosby with the pill in it
i got a whole bunch of cosby albums for
uh steve simone got me gifted got me a
whole bunch of albums nickel now i
wonder if they're uh
i wonder if any of the sets are the
spanish fly sets that's gonna be [ __ ]
up if it is he does do a set about
spanish fly i mean i remember hearing
about that in camp but when you see him
say it now after all that stuff is out
it's about larry king you're like
spanish fly that was big when i was
flying i was big i don't even know if it
worked the guy left spanish flies glove
compartment he went into the grocery
store his girlfriend found it drinks
time he found it came back she was dead
humping the [ __ ]
stick [ __ ] my friend the oceans he gave
it to his grandmother
to see if it worked we all chipped him
we gave him like five hours
and he gave it to his grandpa poisoned
your friend's grandmother not me he boys
in his own ground poison and set her
free he just set that [ __ ] free as [ __ ]
he's in fact it's his birthday today
mike olsen he's 54. i see it on facebook
so
what's happening you bad [ __ ] a
beautiful day to be alive had a very
[ __ ] interesting evening weekend
evening i had a great uh
morning i went i had fungi i still got
fungus under my toenail so i would get
lasered [ __ ] beamed off if you got
fungi under your toenail go get it laser
beamed off for this [ __ ] tremendous
everybody wants to live in the future
here's your [ __ ] chance they shoot
laser beams right in your toes they get
a hose with like water with ice in it
and they condense it i don't know what
the [ __ ] they do when they blow down on
your toes to freeze them then they beam
it because it gets hot every once in a
while you're like ah
and it burns and you could smell your
fungus and your toenail frying in the
[ __ ] air it's only 10 minutes i got
to go today i got to go next monday and
the monday after that i'm going to rub
some [ __ ] my lips
when you start getting fungus in your
toes
yeah ten years ago and then what does it
do
it stinks pushes your toenail out and
the fungi develops underneath and then
so what does it say
you ever see people that have a [ __ ]
[ __ ] up funk uh toenail and hangs over
when you go to the pool yeah oh yeah
that's what it looks like i cut it i
keep it good and i paint it i try to
swahili and jiu jitsu i put a [ __ ]
band-aid on it but it always falls off
paint it and people see that [ __ ]
infested [ __ ] toenail
would give somebody a 50 to sniff it
just lift that [ __ ] away put
that big old toe in his nostril and take
a big old [ __ ] like it was
a lick or sniff does it smell
yes it smells it doesn't smell like you
don't smell it in the air but sometimes
native late at night i cut the toenail
underneath its mouth yeah underneath it
smells hard when you let that it's like
a toe jam but a little tougher and you
spill it around your finger and then you
put that ball on your counter yeah you
wake up in the morning you smell that
ball you almost [ __ ] die ugh that's
disgusting male [ __ ] sometimes i'll do
that i'll dig underneath the toenail
like like i'll have here and then i'll
dig if that's a tornado like under like
that
and then smell what's left oh it's
horrible twit that we're lively
people know i'll tweet them i don't know
i've forgotten [ __ ] welcome to the
church of beautiful i did something this
weekend that was
completely out of my [ __ ] character
mother i drove two hours to jiu jitsu
tournament
two hours on the five
saturday to watch one yeah at three
o'clock and he had two in the afternoon
i decided me i thought you were joking
no man
you know i don't do much and and people
come to the shows and stuff and i always
feel guilty they don't negotiate enough
things like yeah
like how could at this point in my life
good afternoon i could sit there for a
basketball game a football game you went
through a legged game with your laker
game you know you experience it but i
can't go watch stand up or right
improv comedy i'll go watch a play if
somebody knows of a good play in
hollywood you know what i thought of on
the way here
let's go see that angela lansbury play i
wonder if she's still good i heard she's
working really good down on the i mean
she's been an actor for 75 years it's
right there right on the prepar
probably somewhere around there probably
tickets aren't expensive i want to see
if you can get better with it when
you're that older
w it's across the board yeah yeah they
say it's a great advantageous the
fantasies it's the pantages it's across
the w there it's a great [ __ ] and
listen bro the older they get the better
they get i wonder if they skip they stay
sharp mm-hmm at their 70s they could be
a [ __ ] powerhouse murder she wrote
was in like she was old then that was a
long time ago how she's still alive
those people take care of themselves
what do you think lee how was your
weekend congratulations on yourself they
had did you see uh billy crystal's new
thing it's not like it's like it's like
a one-man comedians on comedians or
something no no yeah they give him a new
show which is probably gonna be terrible
but his hbo special like 300 sundays or
whatever yeah with his dad it was like
half stand up half one man show with
like pictures and stuff it was pretty
cool yeah half of you watching show no
left not again no it had left i mean his
entire audience is old is like 90 90
years old billy crystal has a precise
audience my mom loves them 50 year olds
older jews and they go and that's their
pride and joy really they dress up they
spend a little bit they even take an
extra 20 out of the atm yeah they live
it up with billy cruz there's just some
jews that jews go out for and live it up
like they make jews proud
and you don't know until you go like i
see it because i'm a non-jew so when i
go like when i went to see bette miller
i went to see bet milton 30 years old
phenomenal matt miller will do three
hours she'll do stand up she'll sing
she'll dance
but it was filled with jews who for that
night they forgot they were that was a
super bowl yeah like you could tell they
were very nice you know they won't smoke
pot or nothing but they'll giggle and
they'll turn their head they'll smile
and even the men will loosen up a little
bit like holy [ __ ] one of the first non
animated kids movies like when i was a
kid one of the first like actual adult
movies i saw was mr saturday night my
dad loved them we had we had to be a
chess all right yeah when harry met
sally was massive i forgot about that he
just seems like a has been knocked out
what how is he ever in the movie that uh
isn't bad when he plays a cop
all right with another black guy with
the the dancer
he plays a cop and they [ __ ] it's a
chicago movie they're like chicago cops
he did that like in the 80s billy
crystal's been uh doing with the cowboys
city suckers city slick said he slept
really good yeah he made some good money
he did some good [ __ ] billy crystal's
city slickers hammond sally there were
some really good movies he was in huh my
giant i don't forget it but at least
there was that well 300 sundays is about
him and his his love for the beginning
for his father for his father and what
they did that's what dad said baseball
baseball games you know
it's like a poor man what are you on
though i always saw that just like
the actor version i never got to see any
of woody allen stand up was he funny i
don't know it hurts an album i have no
idea i think so but i don't know he was
like dead spanish yeah deadpan you know
like very like uh well they all wanted
to be the crazy jew so
yeah what's the question
who's the crazy joke from the 60s the
reason why we're here lenny bunny bruce
if you watch that the one i always talk
to yeah the black and white one that's
one of my favorite pieces of stand up
yeah
yeah man because yeah
i never seen any of that is it good yeah
it is good you catch it you're like damn
look at this [ __ ] because
yeah he was jazzy he had a great rhythm
to it
but that was interesting i had never
been to a jiu jitsu tournament before oh
yeah i'll tell you what the most
interesting thing was about it what that
i don't feel bad being that fat in a jiu
jitsu no more why not cause there was
a ton of fat jiu jitsu guys no really
really and they're tremendous after a
certain level
like after they hit a brown belt yeah
they get bigger like they get bigger and
fatter like with a strong fat yeah and i
saw this one black belt uh pole guard
and he almost ripped the other guy's
shoulders off oh because it's so big
he's holding 300 pounds he just
it was very interesting to see them take
that top saw i mean i went to see
something else i didn't go to see that i
just went to see a tournament neon
bellies and yeah you know
you see like eight eight fights going on
at once it was like six fights was going
on once doris was dead no really ashton
was there the whole machado family but
they're all the the gracies were there i
watched the one with tate in long beach
yeah they're [ __ ] i mean i was and i
appreciate the jiu jitsu a lot this when
i was a kid well that's when i lived in
new york renato was there or what's the
kid's name the black kids
was there
we had a great time my friend hugh was
there you know when i was a kid not when
i lived in new york city i did karate
with lauren joe's father when i lived in
jersey i gotta say three years of my
life
you had to go to three things a weekend
with this karate gushing guru karate
where i went in jersey the guy's name
was
kevin norland or something and he was a
vietnam vet but he was not all there
remember we talked about him somebody
called in he goes he still teaches
and he wanted you to go to three things
a month you only have one sunday off a
month or one saturday
so he would check him off like before
you sent your application he would check
him off so every month he went to the
bronx that's what i did guys before i
started smoking dope me and six idiots
like you would get together at eight in
the morning with our karate keys and we
take a bus somewhere and we take a bus
we go to an auditorium with each spar
not with each other in a tournament we
do forms
and then three of the six would take a
gold or a platinum or whatever the [ __ ]
the metals are and we'd go home once i
started smoking pot i didn't want to be
with those guys no more
not that i didn't love them i was just
too embarrassed they didn't get highly
uh ari all they did was do karate so
these guys didn't understand that world
so the more i got high the more i
distanced myself from those guys which
was my [ __ ]
i would have been a killer if i found
those guys those guys were great guys
but that's what they did and that's this
lifestyle like the kid
i saw travis nawaza now he owns a
t-shirt company he's friends with eddie
he dates a friend of mine who travis he
went saturday to this thing which was
the world
whatever jiu-jitsu tournament which is a
league
and then sunday he was going to go court
to do another tournament in the morning
and he got onboarded really at the
tournament i was at he just likes
competing yeah but he took a gold
yesterday two categories wow so that's
the life we bomb we do good and it's all
forgotten again yeah you just keep
rolling
so it was very interesting to see that i
learned then i you know
obviously at this age i can't do a
tournament
every [ __ ] week and prepare for a
tournament i die you know i go to once
twice a week i walk around saw for three
[ __ ] days so but it's very
interesting
listen guys i said i was every time i
went by an exit i wanted to make a
u-turn why because it was bumper to
bumper oh you wanted what's it take to
get the [ __ ] herb on a good day 45 45
yeah it took me two hours no on a
weekend on a weekend on a saturday well
the five guys you got walt disney you've
got
whatever farms you got san diego you
know you got people going places viva
library
what's up with you negro talk to me so
you got
the special premiered last week what a
favorite library i mean
viva libre live [ __ ] freely
so your special ed last weekend
especially on friday yeah thanks i got a
tape that watched the first 10 minutes
the baby started crying so
well after i did the babies
i make him cry that's like comedy's good
for it so now thursday night you have
storytellers coming on yeah this is not
happening okay
no yeah key is doing it probably funny
it looks pretty funny yeah yeah he told
a good story about a crackhead crackhead
so
it's you know what uh whenever i read
about this this is not happening yeah
the big push they say is how you started
this from ground zero ground zero went
online and then they got the television
something that really doesn't happen in
this town that much well it was a show
at the improv the show in the side room
of the improv the side room with 40
seats side room no alcohol we weren't
even allowed to bring it in before i
even met you joey the first show i ever
saw in l.a was uh your show with uh
job stories and canaan went up what was
it were those in the main room yeah
that was the first show i've ever seen
in any others five bucks yeah yeah five
bucks experimental try some [ __ ]
i'm trying to break the bank
try some [ __ ]
look at comics you know don't feel like
you have to yeah we did it in that side
room 12 people were there you were on
that show you were on the first one me
baron you married steve aggie uh-huh who
else dylan brody
wow he's like a storyteller and then uh
and damodonia eddie brill's illegitimate
son
was on the first one wow
right now look what it's become
yeah now it's going to grow once it hits
tv it's going to be like a rap battle
but madonia did did one about it was all
it was all psychedelic stories don't
even know about chasing his friend benji
outside on fountain at [ __ ] 1 p.m
naked running trying to find benji
getting arrested on mushrooms naked and
arrested while you're on mushrooms then
that brody guy talked about peyote
and how these indians gave him [ __ ]
peyote when he was 14 at indian sleepway
camp they're like it's time let's go
and then
you talked about that concert was it
exactly like a pink floyd concert is
that the one that got filmed and the
trip to it yeah yeah cool that was the
first that was the first one it got
filmed in two parts i didn't know how to
make a youtube video it's one of the
shittiest [ __ ] youtube videos of all
time but people liked it though when
they saw it
the pop-off that's when you first talked
about pop-off
papa vodka papa vodka
and then uh a.g talked about getting
laced at a grateful dead
and uh marin talked about uh taking some
some shrooms or some acid or grateful
day
amazing that's how it [ __ ] started at
least
did you guys have any like idea when you
were starting the show of maybe getting
on tv are you trying to do a show we
just want to do one good show we didn't
want to get it going again but everyone
had such a good time
it was still fun and cool 12 people were
in the audience
who's it
belladonna was there
with her husband she was one of the two
of the twelve
this porn star family
yeah it was fun as [ __ ] and then eric
abrah he's like dude let's do that again
so we did it again or something else
another topic
yeah that was five years ago i still
have the poster that kevin christie made
this sweet [ __ ] giant like size of
that thing hand painted
psychedelia and these crazy fonts
save it [ __ ] that of course i'll save it
it says joey dsd veggie put that
yeah exactly
there's only two i got one and
and once the zoom's got one eris got one
yeah that was cool that was fun man we
were there from the beginning that's
cool yeah and then later they were like
let's do a web series we tried to pick a
picture to a show a few times like
a couple years in but
they were like maybe with some other
host
and i was like
last week on the rogan podcast we spoke
about when we first started going out
with them together yeah how people hated
us
hated us why are you bringing these
losers hated but the main spokesman for
the losing contingency bag here we go
sanford i was just there i [ __ ] hated
that guy
and everybody hated him i had heard
about that he was a dick for years and
all he did was talk [ __ ] about us oh he
did he's talk [ __ ] tonight oh rogan's
gonna bring his losers again he talked
[ __ ] to two people that came turned
right around and went back to me so i
always knew so every time these people
talk [ __ ] to your friends and expect you
to tell you is this the booker up there
the booker up here
he's fine okay
and he uh we went and every time
and it was funny because the last time i
saw him he pulled me aside he goes hey i
might get you this gig
and i remember thinking look at this
[ __ ] guy coming around yeah because
there's a show and i really want to get
you on it but sharipa doesn't want you
on it
but i've been pulling for you like a
[ __ ] you know that could easily
make sure ripper wants you and he
doesn't it's so uh
and it's such a feeling that guy must
feel bad now like there's so many people
that gotta feel [ __ ] bad there's
still a lot of people that [ __ ] hate
me i hate them just as bad like the
other night
you know what they don't even i don't
even think they think about it i just
think they go oh cool that guy's doing
great and they don't even remember how
much they [ __ ] said you were and go
nowhere no they remember there's certain
people that i [ __ ] with them now like if
i say listen the greatest thing madonna
ever did was about eight years ago
madonna madonna had a
a raffle and a thing of all her
rejection letters oh really and they
said people were running for [ __ ]
cover
that [ __ ] saved every rejection all
these people all these [ __ ] things
never be anything
your voice is horrible
where do you think you are leave her
rejection sorry the rejection and not
even until she recorded her first album
even after that she was a superstar for
25 years she still saved them you guys
were both too young to remember 1985 30
years ago no no right now madonna had
this country like it was her michael
like she was televised i remember
everything the the gloves i was 11. yeah
the gloves everywhere the stocking
gloves whatever they're called although
everybody everybody was just like a
virgin
everybody every chick had gloves glasses
the blind and then she switched it up
with vogue and all that [ __ ] and you're
like wow she was massive her book when i
was in israel her book came out of like
seven pictures
yeah 92 92 yeah she put the this is what
this [ __ ] did but
she put the book out with the pictures
of her naked she made rodman look good
yeah she took the she made the pepsi
video and she got five for putting the
black jesus oh yeah life is uh oh yeah
and then her thing was one of the first
things to get banned and go massive
massive she sold so many actual copies
also ghs copies of that video she knew
she was gonna [ __ ] with them they
wouldn't put on tv so fine i'll sell my
own and be a millionaire officer
and then you'll play it you'll play it
eventually justified by love just was
she's getting [ __ ] like an animal yeah
let me see that monitor [ __ ] don't
hide it from me just
justify my love yeah she was uh i
masturbated her so many times yes yes he
was bad ass man yeah her pictures her
black and white pictures are gray she
had hair on their armpits oh yeah
he remembers that [ __ ] we block it
let me see that monitor this is just
[ __ ] this is just [ __ ] big screen
it
yeah oh she's already half naked what's
she doing she's coming from getting
[ __ ] up yeah she's had makeup with
sperm on her breath oh yeah she's been
drinking martini she doesn't know what
flavoring i'm about oh my god look at
that she was like i'm selling stuff
who are those people
she's dropping a briefcase
what was that a guy or a girl i don't
know doesn't matter that's madonna
he's taking us oh my god can the people
see this no
wait actually
oh [ __ ] jesus dude
oh my god
oh my god
what year is this 91. oh my god [ __ ] a
lot of delray oh my god
oh my god
that half kiss thing
[ __ ] she's hot
oh my god
oh someone else is [ __ ] in the
she's a savage guys
our marketing is [ __ ] marketing 101
oh my god she pushed the envelope they
banned her and then she double up
she doubled up on everybody dog oh my
god i'm horny as [ __ ] now well go
believe yourself
and jerk off on the floor like a like a
peep show girl lee she's she was so high
i forgot it but all i see is that
[ __ ] dinosaur now how old was she
then
she was 30 she broke late
but even at 40 she was looking kind of
good she had enough she's like 71. it
she was like doing the kabbalah nah she
is 71. jennifer lopez looks really good
no [ __ ] that she borrowed time before
you don't like jennifer lopez not at all
why are you still she used to be hot
she's did you see that video she just
did with iggy azalea no yeah whose ass
is the [ __ ] fattest uh something like
that
i think that's the white name of the
song
that's the fattest
put the pizza down iggy put that pizza
down
scared too much it was chubby and then
it's too much now
i don't know why she started bothering
about eight years ago her christina
aguilera
they just [ __ ] pissed me off
this one is cute you know i like
christine aguilera what she came into
ellen after her after she had her baby
and you know how women when they have
when they get pregnant their boobs get
big she's wearing this she's already had
big boobs she's wearing this like
cleavage like cut shirts just on the
cleavage she sits down
ellen said please welcome melanie i mean
christina aguilera she comes in ellen's
[ __ ] staring at those tits she cannot
stop staring and christine's like it's
good to be here and zig and she goes
yeah it's good to have you
um
and then i looks up goes so you had a
baby huh
oh they were
anyway
so i like her for that
so we were talking about the [ __ ]
comedy central thing oh yeah this
thursday and every thursday for how long
eight weeks eight weeks
eight weeks about the last one and the
very last one as usual
you're closing it out every your
headlighting thing
standard revolution everything they're
headlining stand-up revolution they put
me on after the janitor at like midnight
i [ __ ] one i got there at eight and i
got one up at one of the ball and they
always put me up
[ __ ] last it's the it's the worst
ever and people oh yeah yeah you're
going up no i'm not going to [ __ ]
last these guys all got better credits
to me
[ __ ] you [ __ ] i'm going up
third
it's a great story i requested it i want
that to be the last one
you know man you're one of the few
people who don't give a [ __ ] when they
say joe diaz you're like he's doing it
he's doing it and that's it gabriel it
was the first discussion yeah right we
were a meeting he was like well should
we have people if i'm like well joey
will do it
and then let's start booking it now
it's crazy and it's a great feeling when
your friend i remember gabriel pulling
me aside going dog
they were like no no no no no he goes i
just sat in that room and said yes yes
yes yes they didn't fight me on you they
didn't find me to do it i am out of your
pocket
because that's what he told me he goes
i'll do it out of my pocket really and
i'll put it on my own dvd i do diaz just
for me
and they all agree they were all down
there the same [ __ ] people that down
there whatever down to arizona and i had
to go up in front of them and it's the
weirdest thing because they try to put
them a look up
they put them a like on me you know i'm
a like
so [ __ ] done what do they do
they just stab me down oh really oh so
then you get word because you know they
don't like you yeah so then you're like
yeah that's what performance environment
yeah you know
you just know
the other night it's like when i went to
that place for the other night i felt
the heat from people what place oh that
comedy right just too many people who
didn't like me there was just too many
there was an assortment they're like
what's this rust about [ __ ] is this [ __ ]
there were a lot of people that did like
you no when they showed that preview
video you're the only one that got claps
you and miss pat
i'll be tasting like audible claps i
wanted to tell the darkest story you
should've [ __ ] those people you should
have that's the show no no say whatever
you want those people were not gonna
handle me hitting somebody with a bat
his eyes rolling and we thought we
killed them
that was great they did it you got to it
eventually they loved it and it's funny
because i have not seen a picture of
deeney the kid who had
a seat
but yeah he didn't really have it but he
can sarah he's got hiv oh no that's way
worse than hepatitis yeah i don't even
know what hepatitis does i know what hiv
does the other body who died had
hepatitis c from shoot uh steroids you
die from hepatitis c you could die isn't
that pre-hiv yes
well i i don't know i'm sorry
no it's not i'm so sorry there's two
episodes
yeah there's two episodes there's two
hepatitis i think they could be i don't
know
i had a friend who had the really bad
one the one that you can't drink alcohol
you can't do it ever again
yeah but he did whatever the [ __ ] he
wanted to he was like borderline [ __ ]
when you have to go do the thing with
your blood
every week
for you to justify my life but that's
always been tough for me is like before
me
like whenever you see jordy with his
buddies i don't like those people jordy
jordan's cool right join these cool boys
because they're just straight yeah
they're straight and straight and you
look at them as the pa those face the
people that rejected you for the last 15
years well you look at them like you're
at the job position of the people who
say joey diaz other [ __ ] i
don't underst i don't know i i have a
hard time with so many levels
of this business i cannot
i'm happy that you're doing well because
it gives a lot of people a black eye
because most people who listen to the
show and people at home don't understand
how the comedy thing works here when you
get here harvey how many people weren't
even up to your level
and we're already with three yards oh
yeah deals guys like you and me are
sitting there going come on what the
[ __ ] can we just make a dollar and
people just get an audition and we would
get doubt bro i met with every agent
i met with every agent in this town that
would go i love you but now i gotta sell
you 15 people and that's going to be
tough is it just more marketable and has
nothing to do with skill at that point
part of it but it's also you know
who they see you with too right i was
dirty i was way dirtier on early on and
then you know eight years passed and
they will go oh that guy's filthy and
it's like
you know it's fine to be filthy but i'm
not as bad as you think i am
you just haven't seen so they get a head
thing in your head or you they associate
with rogan it's like oh you must be a
meat head
you're not all right i like nick apollo
used to think i was an alt comic because
i work cardigans
and he's like oh you must love janine
garofalo i was like what are you talking
about
he's like i can see you
so people see you it's one way and
that's it i don't know he slipped
through the cracks
you know when i moved here in 97
the store was very cocaine there's coke
really it's not coke anymore and uh
i was a coke guy i was a coquette and i
was part of that circle and i heard and
somebody pulled me aside it was like a
99
like in 99 somebody pulled me aside and
said hey man
i was and you know who started the first
guy luke torres ah
luke torres went to a meeting in the
meeting he goes joe diaz that cokehead a
week earlier i give him like ten bumps
of coke
so this is the sound this is what you
need to worry about like i was doing
coke with this guy yeah and a week later
he goes to a pitch meeting that a friend
of mine it says europe that cokehead he
goes that cokehead oh that's not a very
friendly thing to do
no no there's less supportive than the
latino community
but that no one's less supportive but
that's what i was saying to you
uh something i'm saying with smoking pot
that
i've been involved i've been in prison
like in a halfway house situation i've
been in prison
you know i've lived in situations where
i was surrounded with scumbags because i
was a scumbag you know not for long
periods of time but people you had to
watch yourself at every level like you
had to put your hands in your pockets in
your sleep
like that that's how bad it was because
you never [ __ ] knew
comedians to me
without the violence just with the
emotional
are worse people
than the people i was locked in with in
prison because they do something worse
to you than rob you if i come up to army
and i go all right give me 300 bucks i
needed to pay the rent i don't pay hari
again that's it
i don't pay army again army gets mad at
me i'll never see ari whatever but
with comics you have like this
fake war that doesn't explore
like you're like you're in competition
but there's you're not in any
competition i didn't do this to be a
competition my theory i want to be the
best one i want to get any better than
you it's like what i thought you just
want to be a successful comedian my
third year in town i realized that
when you get here you have to cut your
legs out from underneath they do
i saw a girl
her agent was thinking of signing her
friend like her good friend
and she talked him out of it
and she's like no it gets my category
don't do that
and it's like why are you kidding me
and then that decides somebody's life
yeah so they don't get an agent of the
year they don't get a
audition they could have booked in that
time that could have been their friends
how do you live with yourself when you
do it's like i was watching you forget
it instantly i was watching a show
yesterday on blacklist a blacklist and
they were just killing random people and
it's like how do you think you live if
you killed somebody and like be okay
with it how could like i'd be okay if
someone was gonna book joey for a comedy
show yeah and i said oh don't he he's a
bad person compartmentalized that's how
people compartmentalize you ever see the
killing fields or the killings whatever
and they're finally remembering what
they did murdered [ __ ] 600 people and
when they're finally remembering it
they're like oh [ __ ] that was bad but
they don't think about it normally
they're like hey we used to chop their
heads off and stuff it still wasn't
getting set in
what was that movie the killing fields
the documentary
about pol pot and stuff yeah but all
these people that were just like they
were like we had to go here because
there's a courtyard that would catch all
the blood it would fill up it would be
up to our ankles and blood
we don't want to waste bullets so we'd
take
chicken uh [ __ ] piano wire wrap it
around their heads and an eight person
pull
jesus
you know mark baby was a friend of mine
mark babbitt was yeah he stood for baby
and i liked batman even though he was a
[ __ ] freak and i sent him a blank
tape and all that [ __ ] to see if he'd
ever watch it yeah and he never watched
it he told me it was great i never put
none on it and i sent it to him freddie
soto kept torturing me going babbitt
wants to hire him but he wants some tape
if he wants to hire me then he'll hire
me he can hire me what's he need to tape
for oh he needs a tape can you send him
a blank tape and he hired me and he
hired you so why didn't the tape if he
was a if it was because it's just it's
just he just wants you to jump through
the [ __ ] hoop so we became friends
babbitt you know and
when he was doing the freddie the baby
was doing the call with freddie they did
the tour with freddie amigos yeah then
they do three amigos i went let's see if
freddy and pablo and i
went backstage and they had like a
little food set up
and these three copies were 30 feet away
from each other but i could feel the
energy in between them how much they
didn't want to be around each other yeah
like no matter what how funny whatever
it was carlos would go yeah pablo's
plenty of he's a co-cat
you know uh and then you know they would
say something about freddie carlos would
carlos in those days was the type of guy
that he would mess with you before you
went on stage
in little way like he was hosting some
show
hosting a stand-up show and before he
brought johnny sanchez on this is his tv
show or something before he brought
jenny sanchez on he did his main bit and
it's like it won't be in the edit you
know they'll never show it because they
already did my time up front but just
and then johnny's like what the [ __ ] man
why would you do that
i was about to do that whole bit why
would the
that was that's so mean and i remember
one time while they were shooting at
carlos was hosting and freddie was
yelling at pat buckles that he was
quitting because carlos had done his
joke he saw on my mencia he saw there
was like a promo and they showed like
four different clips on either side of
the picture of vencia when it was first
premiered and freddie was crying because
he was like those three of those are my
bits he took three of my bits and he's
put him on the comedy central website
how am i gonna convince anyone those are
my bits
and he was crying about it
it was [ __ ] hard and i learned that
and i was also upset with like the rogan
thing
i you know it's just something i have
with comics never been telling felicia
and felicia didn't understand because
she's such a nice person yeah you know
felicia buys into it
you know then they throw you know they
throw you the [ __ ] out of whatever the
[ __ ] they throw you for me
i always had this silent thing with
comedians i either liked you i didn't
like it yeah sure
you nod and say hello and you walk on or
you don't walk on and you stop and you
talk to people in my world i gotta be
honest here they're the shittiest people
i've ever met
you know when there's so many different
like perspectives that i look at yeah
like i've had club owners call me after
they've gotten fired or something say
hey man how are you doing i pick up the
phone yeah they go good how you doing
you talk to me and it goes man nobody
called me back of course they didn't
really like you that's it because you
don't have nothing to offer
right we're so trained here you know
it's not about friendship it's about
like you're my friend i like you of the
people i have to do this with okay if
somebody came up to me and said ari
sofia is a rapist
and ari came up to me a week later and
goes dog i'm a big time comic i want to
take you on the road
but i'm going to pay you three thousand
dollars in your meals you know what
in real life you go
in real life i'd go go [ __ ] yourself but
as a comedian
tolerated
yeah and his rapisms
you know there's comics that are gay
that's what taylor said about mencia it
was if he just gave comics parts shitty
like [ __ ] 200 parts on his show
no one would have really defended it
they just would have been like you know
you shouldn't do it but whatever i've
never been big on people who sell their
souls at any point in their life
so i never understood
the whole
that's why i know about you when you
were like when you were like they make
you [ __ ] give up your cats he's like
[ __ ] i'm not giving up my cats and
you're like what are you gonna do like i
gotta move
i'm gonna pay twice as much in rent and
go yeah what am i gonna do give him what
kind of man would i be if i give up my
pets to save money on rent
what would i do yeah so you moved to
north hollywood you never thought you
could live in north hollywood lee said
something to me where hollywood born and
bred oh my god i love hollywood but then
the traffic was killing me at least
that's up to me last night we spoke
about just general [ __ ] football yeah
and he told me did you see that game yes
he told me he went to the gym yesterday
24 hour fitness and it was empty yeah
since january first it's been packed oh
because of the resolutions so that means
on the seventh on the 18th the
commitments were gone
not even three weeks three weeks in
that's how we are as friends to one
another a lot of people in this town the
first week of the year i took 20 minutes
to get a parking space and then
yesterday no one was there no loyalty no
loyalty there's really nothing you know
always like dave rath no matter what
because he was there for freddie when he
died he was there like taking care of
the funeral agents as we were all
weeping and stuff he wasn't even
representing freddie but he stood up and
done it and then brodie stevens too when
he started going crazy dave wrath was in
charge of all that and i was like you
know what you gotta be loyal to [ __ ]
like that no matter what happens down
the road you gotta be like all right man
you're always gonna be cool you need a
hand up
yeah people don't they forget they're
like whatever we're that you're i never
run below me now i never
understood was forgetting
i never understood people forgetting and
then when people tell me something like
that about people
it shuts me down like a human being but
then you said you sell a story two
different ways like we were talking
about you and justin talking about how
marin's manager was like oh he wasn't
loyal he got big and then he dropped me
but you hear from the other side marion
was like look i'm not doing anything
you're not going to be single audition
i'm going to try this podcasting stuff
and his manager was like nah stupid idea
won't go anywhere so then he dropped so
then the story gets sold that he's not
loyal but it's like no this guy was a
piece of [ __ ] he didn't believe in me
anymore he didn't bother i dropped him
and then grew so it depends you know
people sell those stories both ways
and then the best part i'm sure you just
dealt with it how many people who were
shitty to you
wanted them to be on your new tv show
dude yeah
no i didn't really get any of that
really i wouldn't really get any of that
but when i booked my first commercial i
remember people like saying hi to me
that like you wouldn't even give me the
time of day and now you're coming up to
me and saying hi how you doing because
you think i'm doing because i'm more of
a player
in the biz
it feels really good i would say hi to
you and you would walk by me you know i
told i said eddie griffin i told that
once i was this girl who like did that
at dublin she was like oh hey how are
you doing i said commercial i've tried
to say hi to you like 20 times i didn't
say anything as eddie griffin i was like
did you get that because yeah because
you know how you get back at them i was
like how he goes you have sex with them
that's how you get back with them you
have you [ __ ] them
just cash in man who cares
i told rogan that because he never
really you know rogan's had his career
yeah and we've been around rogan and he
thinks that everybody's career is the
same way yeah you and i both know that
it was not everything
whenever he's like oh that club owner is
nice to me oh really really everyone
says he's an [ __ ] he's nice to you
what do you think that is
so uh i told them that
your life changes dramatically once
somebody sees you on tv
even if it's just having one line
because now you changed
now they know it could happen yeah not
today maybe that wasn't the role but it
could [ __ ] happen we don't want to
have to tell you no
right so people just say oh keep in
touch they don't want to say no i don't
see it
they don't say it don't say that i've
always said that uh just say it just
like look i don't see uh this happening
with you right now one of the biggest
things that bothered me about best of
luck
were people not getting back to me in
the beginning wait wait wait wait wait
wait please call me they don't ever want
to tell you no because you might
remember him later on he's the guy who
[ __ ] well regular job interviews do
that too no one gets calls back ever
well you have to call them
oh i've never done that you have to call
them when you apply for a job yeah you
gotta you're in the car you gotta follow
up i call that [ __ ] thank him
and then a day later i called him to ask
him if he got all my paperwork in did
you get everything you needed maybe i
forgot some of the applications no i got
everything here and then i didn't attend
the guy would go well i got you on the
phone let me get you back for another
interview or you got the job just
because yeah because they're like oh uh
you know what you oh look at his
application he was like the guy wasn't
bad he had he hadn't gotten to it yet oh
i got to go over those [ __ ] ten
people decide who uh
yeah yeah you seem fine man yeah come on
yeah go ahead
why not impress me your salesman call if
you go for a salesman job and you're not
saying you don't call that [ __ ]
from the car the house the hotel the
plane then you're not gonna get it
because that shows them you're
persistent that's how you sell something
nobody's gonna sell you something the
first time they call you come on chad
i'm gonna call you the fourth time jack
grab the card i'm going 4-0 today i got
the new england patriots going [ __ ]
big
one of the shows i worked on this kid
got his job because he just was walking
around handing out resumes he ended up
sucking but he got people used to
because of it people just throw their
rolled up scripts in in uh convertibles
as they were leaving the studios oh god
remember that as i used to say they roll
up their scripts put rubber bands around
them and as people were driving out of
the studios and their commercials people
would throw their scripts into the cars
like get people to read their script
that's another thing i don't understand
about how you live with yourself
who's ever reading that script ever it's
so scummy like who could who could be
like that creepy about it and live with
yourself that's another i don't know
read this it's so good you'd be [ __ ]
surprised that they
listen
i'm a christian came back to me i hated
that i had a guy call me in for a
meeting once strung me a long story and
then called me in for a meeting i went
in there with me for a manager and he
was like okay yeah it's like
uh thanks for coming in so listen i
don't think we can work with you uh
we're kind of full right now i was like
wow and then he starts talking about the
reasons why and what the business is
going and what i'm just tuning out now
at this point and i'm just looking
around this office and i'm like why am i
here
why am i in beverly hills it's until 8
30 on a tuesday i should be in bed
i woke up just tell me
you could have told me this on the
[ __ ] call the meeting yeah it's like
having to come in to get fired yeah can
you call me in validated parking
walk out how was your meeting uh what
was that i went to 30 of those
why am i here
i told that shandra she was like i don't
know why i would have called you in to
see that say that i remember when i
first got here
there used to be a place on santa monica
boulevard that did kami and the industry
was all over it wasn't largo
there was one over where uh
oh my god downstairs so it was largo and
then there was something else oh yeah
yeah yeah yeah yeah but that was the big
alt room that was the big luna lounge
luna lounge this is 98. i don't think
what they were watching on this street
was if you blew up luna lounge you
walked out that's it you're in you're at
least had a development deal for your
own show to make but it was right it was
getting on that was a [ __ ] so
unless you knew somebody who could
like there was one kid who'd get you on
but he tormented he did 55 minutes in
between yeah oh really so it was him and
he put four comics on but the show
lasted three hours because he did 30
minutes in between
everybody because different people
booked every night right because he
wanted to get a deal
and he was horrible he had big ears he
was hard i forget what the [ __ ] guy's
name was who was it i forget what his
name was but then
then there was a place uh santa monica
that was like a restaurant jeans and it
was i got the same thing with these
shorts on today
and it was wednesday nights
at 10 o'clock
and i left there one day
and the next time i get to the store and
scott day is there and scott day comes
downstairs and goes hey man
these people came by today they want to
sign you
i go scott there you serious he goes
they're [ __ ] great
they're great they used to be a soap
fact a soap opera
a soap opera agency yeah but now the guy
over there left
water brothers he's got all these people
i forget who's that big guy at the time
pierre
was over there was an agency yeah but
now they're huge now it's like that they
merge with somebody else
so i go down there oh we loved you the
night the laugh factory or at that place
not luna lounge all right uh we'd like
to come see you again hold on one second
those days all you had to do was scroll
scott day scott i'm here with joe's
showcase they put you on boom 9 30 9 30
9 15 905 you got a primo spot yeah catch
up to win tommy stewart set you up to
win thank you no one could bump you they
just start by yourself then you start
doing fake [ __ ] uh yeah sure like young
was the kid like that was the king of
that he called them for showcases 19
straight weeks
we're gonna take away the system from
everybody yeah well your guy keeps not
showing by accident get out of here if
your guy's not here you can't go on
stage so they came to see me this time
they brought like six people yeah okay
i called them what's up oh we loved you
now we gotta bring uh accounting
bookkeeping how stressful is that
it's a [ __ ] nightmare when all you
want to do is do something because if
you go to an agent they tell you we
can't sign you let me see you're real i
got no real i got no agent okay we go
get a real come back how am i gonna go
real if i got no [ __ ] agent so you it
was a catch 22. so all i wanted to do
was get a theatrical agent mitzi was
getting me spots i wanted a [ __ ]
theatrical agent i was here like four or
five months this was it i went to ross
and bought a shirt a tie
this was it they were [ __ ] huge this
guy had just left warner brothers the
assistant had left [ __ ] caa
this guy had left this they were a
powerhouse they were on uh you know
where they were across the street from
where you lived upstairs
that's where they were all right when
you remember the thing they knocked down
what you had across the street this way
once they knocked that down it was such
a good view after that yeah this way
when you went this way and you went like
uh 30 feet you had to go through a patio
thing and you went upstairs oh yeah and
they were huge they hold the whole floor
the same really that place went under
that place was empty for [ __ ] decades
so i went over there met who like eight
of them we love you bookkeeping and
accounting has to see you now i had a
showcase okay another showcase nine
o'clock nine o'clock now 14 people came
with suits right from [ __ ] work you
want to talk about nerves mitchie showed
up
everybody was there
boom i killed don't they hug me we're
going to talk tomorrow what do you think
tomorrow boom went down there 14 people
okay now we they wanted to see something
else i talked about that
then there was the christmas holiday
then i went down to like january 20th
and they sat me down six in the
conference room offered me like
pellegrino water
and said you know what we're we can't
we're gonna pass on you right now but
we're gonna keep an eye on you oh what a
[ __ ] two-face we believe you're
somebody to deal with in the future
we're gonna you know and deal with me
now that's like that's like saying like
at best that's like saying develop build
your own career and then we'll take over
yeah
where it's like no i need help now and
then i will stay with you later that's
what it was back then that's what it
basically [ __ ] was jesus christ it
was rough it was rough man nobody was
signing as an agent forget about
managers
then i had bobby slayton's manager who
was [ __ ] horrendous
oh my god i was just sending her checks
because you have to pay them fifty
percent and now i'm doing nothing i've
dealt with nothing and here i am booking
900 jobs
sending her 130 dollars she didn't even
[ __ ] call me with the audition
just because she was my manager
oh my god but megan feigen wanted some
of rogan's money opening for roger money
he's like yeah man give me ten percent
of that [ __ ] what am i right it must
suck though for like managers though so
if like you're a good manager and
someone just gets big and leaves you
right as you're about to make all your
money
yeah but the reason i leave you is
because you're most of the time you're
not doing anything you're not doing
anything
it didn't like you signed a giant deal
before you signed the paperwork like
hold on let me fire my manager real
quick so i can sign this it ain't that
you drop him and you start moving ahead
on your own oh okay
it's commitment 19 days
you just talked about it that's the
national commitment level 19 days so if
i come here and i go i'm going to sign
ari shafir we're going to make this
happen the first three days monday
tuesday wednesday he gets on the phone
right like a slave
he's calling everybody she assigns you
we love ariel we love our he probably
will get you a tremendous audition the
last two and a half weeks you know i
mean everything will happen in like two
weeks and then the first no or the two
no's he gets if you don't get that big
audition nah my heart's not thank you
but they don't just drop you there they
don't drop they don't drop you there
they just go well wait we'll see what
else comes
and then they just hold you for like a
year and you're like come on come on
just say look i gave it a good push i'm
not getting a good response on you it's
kind of a [ __ ] up way to make your
living
because then it's like why wouldn't they
work on people who are making them more
money yeah i get it and then the worst
is when you go out to other clients
because you have something and they pull
you aside and go hey has nick been
working for you like no you haven't
heard from me neither
he sucks probably gets somebody else and
he'll tell you a story about another
client did you hear what he did to
whitney
yeah he told whitney he had that no son
three clients are talking about yeah
because that's how small the community
is we see each other
so all i gotta do is go up to heaven go
come here for a second did he call you
with that yeah what the [ __ ] he
thinking did you delete he told lee
right right right yeah and all of a
sudden that's it now you got three
[ __ ] now you got john gotti all
over again they gotta shoot you they're
gonna shoot you and they're all talking
your heart's not in it you say that all
the time it's like why am i do i have an
audition today do i have an audition
this week then why do i keep seeing you
on facebook during the hours of nine and
five
why are you updating your status on
facebook when i don't have an audition
playing it [ __ ] simple
i don't get that [ __ ] pick up the
[ __ ] phone call somebody
make a connection remember at the old
origin they couldn't even get us into
the [ __ ] casting director that was in
his hall
it was down the hall right on laurel
canyon there yeah it was down the hall
they were both on the fourth floor they
couldn't even get you an audition on csi
miami or the other one that was cast out
of there and they're like come on you
can't get me just for sheer
embarrassment alone of having to piss
next to you every day wasn't the lady
really a [ __ ] there i don't know origin
yeah that's a lauren toy she was a [ __ ]
she was another one that didn't nice
enough but then when they like split up
she was like are you gonna stay here
like what are you talking about you've
never gotten me any uh they're never
given a chance they don't even say hello
and i'm and you know i'm friends with
him and he's changed my life
and you've never done it like why would
you even make this call
what a [ __ ] you would have to be to
accept me coming over there you should
be like no no no no you're his friend
and and he you know
you pretty much only made money over
there we we no you shouldn't come over
here
going out of the way to call
you
we want your money
i want your money
please
what was i remember they had like those
yellow books
oh [ __ ] they had those yellow books and
you could send packages away
oh yeah the samuel french ten bucks you
gotta get it that's the only way to get
an agent
send out 80 80 envelopes
he said four will come back
this is nice
it's as good as it gets though
how many do you guys have how many stars
do you have
unfortunately you know what i'm saying
i've been trying to tell you that [ __ ]
so they had these yellow envelopes yeah
oh yeah and you went to samuel friends
and you paid ten bucks you went home in
the asian envelope they also had a
manager envelope they separated it they
said double their double their income so
then some smart [ __ ] had
the labels
the labels
already mail ordered two william
two gersh to this place to this place so
i would go in there by the book but
shout lift the labels behind the books
because the labels are 1995.
uh so i would shop with the manager
labels but steal that they would tell
you which ones would accept submissions
from non-sag which ones are sag only
they still have i have like an old like
looking for comedians specifically so is
that just before the internet wait yeah
before the internet like i was like why
would that even be a business it was
before before the internet operators did
their internet was around but it wasn't
like that that's crazy yeah people saw
maps in their cars
that's right
and then you had a
you had this [ __ ] thing and you said
the thing they'd say we were looking for
comedians character actors
musicians and that's where you made a
list and you said the demise it's that
yeah they're looking for character
comics people like that they get about
submissions so i sent this thing to this
agency the best way to find a commercial
agent that was the best that was the
best way
all they look at you as their headshot
right and they're like cool yeah they'll
give you a shot with a commercial
because they'll have 300 clients they'll
have 300 clients it's not a big deal
they don't give a [ __ ] they'll give you
10 for each audition you can get in
you'll go on for everything with
commercials so i send like 20 packages
and i get a call from three people and
one of them is a lady she goes i'd love
to meet you
i go all right where's your office i
look at the paper and i go are you still
in sunset she goes uh yeah but uh i'm
working out of pasadena oh wait i go
okay i think i went to that lady and
there was a dump she shared an office
with another guy there was a dog that
was old yeah across the worker from the
golf course and they had tons of head
shots on the floor and everywhere i mean
the only thing they had left off opening
their offices
was like this
it was like quarters it was for
headshots [ __ ] crazy like they were
collecting the dreams of want to be
actors
they were they were just feeding off
their [ __ ] dreams look at their face
she called they were just there was
packed stacks and stuff i hoard her
headshots
pacley
her telling me she would get me on the
tv show in three hours oh my god i
remember her [ __ ] they go why are you in
an office and passing through you
couldn't wrap your head around it but
you wanted to believe you wanted to
believe
she was that [ __ ] good oh this will
get me what i want to dream of
i'll be the actor or something i guess
is that what i'm supposed to want it was
hard
and then it's just on the chance that
you booked something she makes money i i
don't know what chance she can get you
in [ __ ] by all means but
but the classic scam that got worked on
me no it didn't get worked out but she
almost had me
but i didn't go for it was if you listen
to get headshots to my friend which one
that's what i always say you need new
headshots here's here's my
recommendation
this was route when i first moved here
there was a lady who was managing
monique marquez okay
okay decent name she was friends with
james bisson
that's a great color card and she was
hooked she pulled her talent
from
the laugh after me okay so she had a
couple big names
but i mean one of the people she had was
modi
marquez so guess who signs with her at
98.
joseph coco diaz no ralphie bay oh okay
coffee mate comes to town she tells
ralphie you're gonna be a star she's a
jewish woman from miami he grew up
around humans a lot of [ __ ] yelling
she's a great flavor she was a chubby
little jewish woman yelling and
screaming at the comedy store and at the
so what night she calls me on the moon
she goes i watch your set you're filthy
but i have something for you right now
right now i go what is it she goes
here's the deal i spoke to them already
it's a recurring winari i was not ready
what it's a recurring rule and some nbc
show obviously didn't last
and she goes i spoke to them about you
they were not ready
no not at all she goes they want to see
you at 4 30
uh today and they'll probably put you on
12 in those days you signed for 27
episodes or something they'll put you on
13 or 27 episodes i have them on hold
right now
calling you
you want to believe so bad she's calling
a guy not one party goes wait a minute
i've never shot anything in my life my
life and they want me because why would
you not think of someone else at that
point i shot a commercial for taco bell
yeah with a dog and maybe something else
but no there was no hope of me i had one
line or something basically so she said
they're on hold right because i got them
on hold right now all i need is your
commitment fax me i'll fax you a
contract you sign it fax right back to
me that sounds so scary oh my god and
i'll call i will get you on this show
today
you will be shooting by next week you'll
be making fifteen to twelve thousand
dollars i'm gonna be going something's
not right ralphie's been with her for a
month nothing's happened right like she
had like a little livestock of people
so i said no and you don't know what
you're missing and then about a month
later i started hearing [ __ ] up [ __ ]
about that she would charge her clients
it's the money for postage
oh at the end of the month you got a
bill from her that's part of your ten
percent that was part she was that
jewelry guys that at the end of the
month she would send you a bill for the
phone call she made office cost
so you get like a hundred dollar bill
from her every [ __ ] month which when
you're starving comic is a lot i'll
never forget that ralphie comes up to
the store one night really depressed
this is how i met ralphie this is the
conversation that changed our lives when
ralphie moved to los angeles he was a
complete different person
let's get this out of the way
he was completely different he was from
the south he was shy he didn't say much
but when he went on stage he was a ball
of energy and he was big and fat he was
700 pounds yeah he moved to l.a you see
there's old pictures of him and it's
round it's right it's amazing but he was
a sweetheart he lived at doug stanhope's
apartment the war that doug stanhope
gave up with the other kids from alaska
that's the apartment he took over so he
had just moved to this town so it's a
lonely sunday night at the store it's
like december and ralphie's gloomy gus
he's got a long face yeah and he comes
up to me he goes how are you doing
i have her
i have a problem no in those days he
used to call me mr diaz
this is how bad he was ralphie what are
you talking about it's coco joey
whatever
mr diaz assistant yeah what the [ __ ] are
you talking about
so he's telling me how james masala
wants to sign him
but uh
he feels guilty
because he's
being he's been managed by the older
lady and right away i knew the lady was
just well as i knew
she was a scammer and i wanted to tell
him but this kid's so sweet he's not
gonna even understand what the [ __ ] i'm
saying you know
so he's telling me the whole story also
he goes you know she's dying of cancer
and i go no i didn't know you know she's
dying to cancer
so i don't want to dump her on her
deathbed he goes so what do you think if
i sign with jay man go to montreal do i
stay with her i go that [ __ ] got one
from the grave won the banana peel
call her up right now and launch that
[ __ ] and i'll never forget that
he was such a sweetheart of a kid yeah i
did it really crazy and he just looked
at me he kept he he wanted to cry
but the comic in him just let loose
and he was always different towards me
after that
coco that was crazy when you thought
these guys come when they're young and
they're all so religious and like well
i've never even seen or heard anyone
talk like this it was crazy guys he
fired her and slammed with jamie wow
and then
you're supposed to be like
a lady she died and he was she did die
and now ralphie sends money to the
family no way ralphie bought her
something i know if you pull ralphie
aside
ralphie bought her a tombstone
something ralphie did something because
she was ralphie's first manager she
didn't do anything but she put him in
front of somebody okay well that then
she didn't drink something
she did something maybe you know ralphie
ralph he's dying to give me his [ __ ]
money yeah so what kaufman gave me a nug
once the size of a [ __ ]
it was the size of one of those scented
candles for your place what yeah and he
goes he goes look at this look at this
and that was i was just getting into
weed and i was like wow that's like a
really big mug man and i was like i was
like oh i was like cool and i gave it
back to like nah that's for you
what no no we cut no no i'll take it man
i can't do the impression he's taking
care i'm like why because joey diaz gave
me a doug once he only had two
so i always take care of him i'll take
care of everybody
yeah
he's taking care of me since the guy
she's never been without me she's never
that weed since that conversation
ralphie may has taken care of me one way
or another
i'm dead serious of you people right now
he took care of me till
i gotta say five years ago
and he's still all i gotta do is call
all i gotta do is
my tires blew up once i called him like
a ralphie i go on the road for three
weeks he's like don't need to call me
from the gas station
you just put the guy on the phone
it was two tires that blue ralphie
bought before got the suspension fixed
huh you know ralphie's one of those
[ __ ] he ain't just gonna stop
at two tires you know you know that
that was a year
there was a year where ralphie would get
off the road
get the rental car in lax drive to my
house
before he'd even go to his house we'd go
to the pot store buy weed and he'd buy a
quarter pound
that's og a quarter pound quarter pound
quarter pounds in their prime in their
prime
rafi may
is was like the michael jordan of weed
he was like in his prime it's arguably
the big the biggest tolerance of any
company dean of all time i'm smoking
eighth before breakfast
every day can you hang with him joey
yeah oh yeah we used to sit there
just have sessions sessions and then
he'd cook
and then he could um he would cook he
cared so much about cooking
both you guys whenever you gave me a
food recommendation i was going to
poinsettia you got to go to the wok
gigantic portions really delicious
that's when you were fat
and i was like i'm gonna listen to this
guy
on this subject i will be at that which
was the one boy's walk yeah it was right
on the corner poinsettia oh no it's gone
now it's gone now
i
think
yes that was the place i turned you once
you order a single cop double double or
triple combo
triple combo it was two and a half meals
for 13 it was crazy lee i don't know it
was it was like going great what was the
place what's the noodles and good rice
rice and noodles both please thank you
what's up what's the chinese place next
to big win
oh panic experience it was this place
was like uh a [ __ ] family owned panda
express type deal and they didn't give a
[ __ ] wait where places were just talking
about the chinese place on melrose oh
yeah yeah yeah
we used to get soup
yeah it was good everything's good
they're spicy they give you the spicy
right i'd eat it as much as i could
there then take the rest on the one
block walk you gotta take them back to
916 north born sedia
we had a back alley and i had neighbors
in the next to me that would [ __ ] and i
put my glass to the wall and i would
listen and [ __ ] right by my bed
i need chinese food yeah and i pretend
to go take trash out to the alley where
the garbage cans were so i could look in
their window and look at them i got too
scared never got a good look
they [ __ ] all those guys
that guy told me he had a he had a uh he
used to book a lot of commercials i
booked my first one while i was there
and he was like i used to book a lot of
commercials and i was like oh cool it's
like you're still doing that because no
i work at like a wine
cellar an hour or something like i kind
of ran out of money and i was like oh
all right listen
don't spend your money
do you have to like take acting classes
to get commercials [ __ ] no you gotta get
some glasses grow a beard in the old day
wear a wristband that's it yeah that's
it
you gotta look the part bro i'm gonna
tell you you were interested in it last
week yourself i think maybe i should you
should that's quite awful let's talk
about the aqua
get you a little yeah you got any
roly-poly categories left maybe yeah
they'll love you though you'll do great
you'll do great you know what a guy like
you will shoot three commercials a year
i knew some asian kid would just crash
auditions and book him and book him and
because he was so goofy he would go in
there like we love that guy you're gonna
book three commercials a year i know for
a fact make your seven thousand on each
commercial you're gonna get sag
insurance you get insurance i just
qualified again after insurance i don't
know what their insurance is like what's
it like i don't know i don't have enough
time to [ __ ] with you
that's amazing now let's see i don't
know why i thought they joined the
unions why am i not getting the joint
[ __ ] what the come on man guys you know
you make it harder i don't want to get
started another [ __ ] topic here but
this is what's going right now used to
be 13 grand you get plan 1 insurance no
no charge free 100 free i love 13 grand
open you made that racism i love open
criticism and i appreciate it
i take them all like a champion i think
about them and i'll give you my
explanation or my apology or my
agreement on what subject we had yeah a
couple weeks ago my wife and i were
talking and we're talking about
something she goes you know it's because
i times you're [ __ ] paranoid these
people
and i go you're talking about all the
people who [ __ ] i go we just finished a
conversation
about how you told me that
the biggest you have to check your
doctor bills now because they'll just
charge you more always check your doctor
bill like you've built me three times
for this last time you said that's the
last charge and now you're billing me
again why am i why don't you tell me
this she was just telling me this in a
casual conversation it's not like i made
this up and you were just telling me she
goes yeah but that's just you have dumb
bookkeepers
when you check in you think they're
great at [ __ ] excel
nicole they're awesome at it and they
don't make mistakes ever well somebody's
excuse me i've been here for 35 minutes
well when you go to american airlines
and you put your suitcase down you went
another hundred dollars yeah for you
know it's it's it's not it's time people
understand you just call i'm not even
saying nothing bad if you call 18 t's
and go listen i found the better deal or
whatever they want a buck and a quarter
we're always i just pay 160 to leave
directv to leave them you're like are
you feeling me you're [ __ ] you never
worked and i know i'm leaving you're
billing me
it never works
that as an american consumer i get
[ __ ] at one level or the other every
[ __ ] day whether i'm well not gas now
verizon to them dsl [ __ ] a month and a
half of calling them over and over and
over again this [ __ ] never worked they
sent three people and they're like well
we want a hundred bucks for the time
what the [ __ ] are you talking about you
had our box for a month i called four
times a week
you should [ __ ] pay me for my time
talking about the san diego charger
ticket
oh i heard about that
so people get pissed my wife's like you
know you a right to leg i go every day i
talk to somebody who gets ripped off by
a corporate somehow i have to [ __ ] on
them and then enough people they go oh
we're sorry [ __ ] we looked at what
happened we're really sorry like what
happens if i didn't [ __ ] have a
podcast then what you would have done
you just [ __ ] somebody over building
with 360 bucks for tickets that weren't
even real you go back and say sorry
nothing we can do you see how much give
me a hundred dollars hundred dollar
refund like we'll give credit to you
100. credit me all of it
why am i making this call
you faceless corporation
you just keep taking us taking us
we're going to fight back hold your guns
you're going to need them
pouring those guns my wife gets mad at
me and then what about the ticket
company that charges like a 19 service
19 but you see the rogan tickets are 26
bucks a piece
two tickets we paid 89
hoard your guns
89
so they were 29 so it was 60 bucks but
it was a fee of 29 each one has a
separate service fee
each one and i've talked to the people
at the [ __ ]
at the ticket place and they go well
it's the venues it's them charging it i
was like well then do a better job of
publicizing who's doing it because you
look like you have a bad [ __ ] eye you
look like you got a black eye like
you're doing it two service charges
the service charge is when you actually
speak to someone
that's the [ __ ] service
you're not doing service that's what
they do now someone two charges
and it's one click
you gotta be kidding me so you have four
tickets you gotta pay 14 bucks on each
one for what's that what does that mean
service charge is there any other way to
do it okay thank god i'm not the only
person
service charge i thought it was just me
jam was saying it 20 years ago we
weren't listening we're called dumb
hipsters i told him they're robbing you
they're robbing you
people nobody doesn't go to the comic or
the [ __ ] musician that doesn't go to
them at all that's just they're already
getting paid though the venue
they're selling alcohol they're selling
posters they're selling do they think
service is nervous when we go in there
with a t-shirt if they sell a t-shirt
they want 15
yeah they get some of that too that's
why they're like how come oh these these
comics are these whatever musicians are
greedy they're charging 30 bucks
they get percentage of the gross or the
net whatever the big one is so you pay
seven bucks to get them printed
and then they take eight
and then you're gonna raise your price
you're gonna make it two dollars a shirt
you know what's the point
why you get a cut
you know what kid rock does he splits it
down the middle everything liquor sales
t-shirt sales
ticket prices because you can't charge
more than 20 bucks because my my [ __ ]
audience justin tells me a list my
audience won't come it's a good show but
it's not a [ __ ] 75 show
but it's a real good show for 20.
but i know they're drinkers and i know
that's more valuable to you than [ __ ]
you know toriyamos
that doesn't sell any booze sells
[ __ ] depends and that's it
that depends tampax
so he goes i on a 50-50 cut and they're
like all right it's worth it
but what the service charge that's just
them taking it we add more what why 14
and not 12 sometimes
it's just a random charge
the [ __ ] are you talking about you
didn't do it i just had to pay because
there are no more seats on a flight and
i had to sit in row four i had to pay 30
bucks because there were no more seats
you had to pay extra dicks didn't like
not even first class just like higher up
or they cram you in the back you ever
see that empty in the front and the
economy plus empty we're all crayon in
the back like can we just spread out
there's no one in any of those rows nope
no that wouldn't be fair to the people
who paid
but nobody's paid why is there classism
right now why are you forming classism
fine if somebody's in a row let them out
the whole rope but the empty rows let us
go there
it's like hotel rwanda here come on
you're like moses of the year
set us free
hoard your guns
we're definitely going to vote your guns
the more they need the more they [ __ ]
get in business with the government
those corporations you know why you can
make another hundred bucks get the
government to [ __ ] look the other way
i'm surprised they changed laws he's
knocking on the [ __ ] door right now
hold your guns the other day during a
joshua's podcast a black lady did knock
on the door and i almost panicked
because i was still high from the
podcast with you or something so did you
open the door yeah i just wanted to go
to the bathroom but it was a black one i
was like oh because felipe as far as the
one crazy one day and a black lady got
us kicked out of our last
that's what was in the joint little
blood dash
really that's what's in the joint you
[ __ ] it tasted funny
little blood i got it so hot check it
out people
buy it
oh my god my nose is so jammed i can't
even smell it so i'm gonna take away for
this little blonde hash
a little platinum [ __ ] uh it's
platinum
it's platinum uh girl scout cookies oh
girls got cookie's always good this is
tremendous good
listen that weed over at sunset uh
herbal center where i go
they it's great weed but it's a little
moisture time yeah so i gotta go home
and put it in computer paper kind of
under the [ __ ] printer
yeah they let it dry a little bit like
sometimes if i got a lot of wheat it
dries overnight so when i wake up in the
morning it's nice and puffy it's like a
[ __ ] bomb like this morning that [ __ ]
was dry i put it in the bomb i put it in
the pipe bam
i was gone this morning i hate these
cheerios and [ __ ] and hanging a
piece of weed
you told me like
the names don't really matter like one
place someone can call something
something and right right it can be
different like shouldn't they make it so
it's the same everywhere
like so you actually know what you're
getting by the name
is she getting [ __ ] in there who's
yours
this is the russian lady who makes
clothing
no that's what we think is huge sound
proofing in that place
that's how we think you know
but it's not really like that people
sell it according to that market so what
uh weed names so if they have a lot of
weed like whatever enigma og is in the
valley yeah enigma og your favorite
story was gonna be two different
straight yeah that should be good that
should be the same no maui wow is always
the same it might be different grows of
the same but it's the same type of high
listen man i've talked to a lot of these
owners a lot of these owners just say
that this comes in but people won't buy
that name
people just won't buy that name
oh really so there's something
that sells for that market you know uh
whatever's in santa barbara is different
than somewhere else yeah
see that one
they got the tv huh
i don't know she put her tv
the police are probably coming because
hoard your guns
we're not that far from the police
station
is gonna bang on the door yeah let me
give some shout outs here
i love you [ __ ] as you can tell
we're a little stoned to the gills oogie
spooky's awesome and she's really cool
we smoked the ash joint we did some
uh 50 milligram edibles what were they
here are the best stories i have for the
year
you
ali siddique that's a really good one
miss pat crushes it
his pack crushed it
kreischer that was comedy central's
favorite one they all love that one the
most
um azizi did a really good one cordrey
i did a couple good ones why did you
look funny yeah he was he was handling
really well he really prepared really
hard
he's one of the non-comments we had he
really [ __ ] worked hard at it now was
that show children's hospital his he's
on it i don't know if it's his
completely i don't know it might be his
name yeah i think it's his because he
wrote he was very you know that's the
first time ever somebody said the note
to my agent
with children's hospital yeah he said to
note to my agent like listen man joey
came in prepared blah blah blah really
impressive
yeah it was one of those jobs i was like
i don't want to do it the money blows
but at the end of the week the money was
great because it's all over time the
initial is the deal they have is a weird
deal they go it's
2.99 for three days and you're like 2.99
for three days
that's not even you he goes yeah but
after eight hours it's all over the
so the second and the third day it's all
great if you shoot three days you're
gonna get 20 hours of overtime which
right i have to get like 92 hours of
[ __ ] overtime because you're there
from
six in the morning to 12 at night yeah
yeah that's cool for a 15-minute show
but that's what we're saying how like
you need your agent to believe they
believe me for two weeks and it's over
you get a call from someone saying hey
this guy's really good
you should [ __ ]
you know
well they're more likely to like keep
keep helping you that's really helpful
listen the agents that suck are the ones
oh my god
the ones that don't believe in you
are the ones that don't believe
look at these red
are the ones that are coming down
where's the israeli flag i better not be
on the [ __ ]
i would never let that happen i would
never let that happen i forgot i had it
on though
i like these little afternoon podcasts
how do you normally do it at eight
o'clock at night
there's another israeli spy this way and
i pull out my uzi
i like that
it's [ __ ] insane so what do you got
this weekend do you hold this weekend
again home this weekend feel good to be
in la weather nice yeah
so benji had this dog he left me this
dog
so it's like you know what do you have
to take care of it yeah but it's got
i've always wanted a dog but i couldn't
have it because at one i don't have a
backyard you almost kind of have to sort
of and then two i go on the road a lot
yeah you're gonna do
but this is just for three months
so it's like it's like a rental dock all
right and he's got a little backyard of
the doggy door
so you're gonna take it on the road no
i'll just give it to someone else on the
road okay
do you like him what's his name
i just call him i
like dude and stuff is he cute yeah but
he take it for walks yeah it's nice it's
a different living yeah it's great it
gets
crazy every time i walk towards the
doors
they get so excited when i come back
they're excited to see you i miss having
a dog
doesn't do [ __ ] though benji hasn't
trained him to do [ __ ] all i want fetch
won't do anything
he barks at other dogs small dogs he
goes crazy angry
but it's pretty cool when he's inside
i'll sign your lap and [ __ ]
girls must like it
yeah i don't know girls seen it yet
that's nice but is a different taste to
you i mean i know you like new york but
i gotta tell you something do you but at
all
no that's what i was gonna say i've been
walking the dog with my shirt off
in [ __ ] middle of january short my
buddy on saturday i told him it was 82
degrees he didn't believe because it was
full of
and no shirt 82 degrees on saturday
that's pretty beautiful california were
you watching the like football games
yesterday seattle oh yeah like and then
new england do you want to be there no
and that was just rain it wasn't even
snow and
cold wasn't in new england it was 50. no
it wasn't bad it got down to like 40's
later that's still cold when you're
sitting out there for three hours
doesn't get like that here low as it
gets here is 50s at night and that's why
i just turned my heat over 40 30 in
burbank two weeks ago yeah we had like
two weeks and look everyone talks about
it oh my god i had to turn my heat on
two weeks ago it froze i never turned my
heat on in and out of the greatest
in the mornings for a couple days it was
just freezing oh
[ __ ] freezing
but no it's yeah i'm so glad to be back
here now [ __ ] yeah go to the east coast
the weekend can't wait to start seeing
the pictures of the blankets of snow and
slush and just like
when do you go back
april okay
and it'll still be cold
it was this year it was still cold it
hadn't had cleavage day yet it was still
[ __ ] oh [ __ ] it was like cold cold
weather
it is like kind of like the perfect
arrangement because i miss the east
coast east coast east goes from like end
to march
until
i want to say maybe early august because
it gets super hot but you can even stay
through august into october they got
this broth place now that tate told me
about it's [ __ ] bone broth they boil
it down where
like 12th and first okay new york city
yeah brodo he said it's like the
healthiest thing i and i [ __ ] oh they
get so much fun [ __ ] there and you can
go to so many cities like really close
like you go from boston to new york to
philly to washington dc oh yeah yeah
yeah by trains and [ __ ] two-hour buses
that cost like 15 bucks all right relax
we're not mexicans
you don't take buses in new york well no
no no no new york i know you're right
yeah not not about it not the city buses
but like boston new york buses i've
taken buses here now and it really is a
lot of mexicans they were right my first
buses i ever took here what the [ __ ] are
you doing oh ball itch
i got shorts on playing that little duck
joey joey did a tour on a bus
so what he did tours on greyhounds he
said i did yeah you just tore around the
couch i used to fly to new york get off
my friends would pick me up and then and
i'd go out of port authority in new york
city yeah you could basically go around
the [ __ ] world i'm telling you right
now you're going to appoint attorney go
up to greyhound go look
i want to go around the world you give
that lady 10 minutes you'll figure it
out she'll figure it out she'll figure
it out dog that'll take you you know a
lot of when i was a feature act or like
headline d rooms or c rooms you know
i would go to new york and
as a comic when you're a feature you're
not looking to pay sixty dollars a night
for a hotel you're gonna crash on
somebody's floor or whatever yeah and
most of the times i go back east
somewhere i know he's gonna answer the
phone right club they go up down to
shore i didn't leave a key for you you
know they go [ __ ] it
let's say i had to be in dallas on
wednesday and i was in new york on
monday i called i called graham to go
what's it cost we have an express for 90
dollars i was going to fly on there for
400 bucks
i got another dude with kill time so you
just left on the on the bus for three
days it wasn't above you could get from
dallas to new york in 24 hours on the
ground express you just sleep on the bus
24 hours here you know they let you off
for two hours all right
you take a shower at one place it's a
[ __ ] night man but it's it's not
gonna kill you i've heard of people
taking seven days jf harris does that
now they have the the mega bus if you
had one of the first it's a dollar yeah
if you get one of the first couple
things and so he's on it he's on it
waiting for it to go on sale trying to
get that dollar so you can save money on
the road
i don't know they have just a bunch of
different bus companies now that like
there's one here that goes from ellie to
vegas
uh
yeah it's pretty crazy
shivers
and what is like a party
no no it's just a cheap
and the [ __ ] up thing is is a lot of
these smaller companies because it's
greyhound but then a lot of these small
companies are owned by greyhound oh
right they own like three they're
serious all the ticket companies are all
by the same people
ticket master buys them all so
you see so you're like oh it's a
different company that could be that can
be for a little bit and ticketmaster
grabs it you're sticking it to the
corporation but not really
but uh they're cool i mean i took them i
couldn't imagine doing what you're doing
i i once looked and it took two days to
get from here to boston like two and a
half days on a greyhound let's look to
see what what wrote it how much
like 170 not bad wow
so i think it was a while ago did you do
two days with no shower on the bus you
asked me what it is with no shower but
you shouldn't
i would never want to sit next to you
for two days either one of you i don't
want to sit next to anybody
[ __ ] two days you don't think
you would stay for two days oh i would
smell so bad yeah i smell bad now
can you imagine two days
just sitting monday morning oh wednesday
afternoon with no shower your ass your
legs are [ __ ] rigatello right yeah
they're [ __ ] and then what are you
eating
yeah you're really garbage yeah french
fries at a truck stop
and then move on
oh my god
i did it that's why i'm you know
i don't think i went two days without a
shower you know me i'm anti-fucking
dirty [ __ ] you could because you
could miss a bus and just taking a later
bus i didn't bad it was rough but i
[ __ ] pulled it off i don't know how
and i would go from toronto in those
days all the way to
atlanta georgia i took an amtrak toronto
to georgia miami to atlanta [ __ ]
amtrak would be fun though i like amtrak
i'm trying i like trains i take them in
canada sometimes it's just really
expensive it's expensive
way more expensive do you think it'd be
it's almost comparable with the airlines
because they [ __ ] you at every level
okay see that oh yeah well how much for
the ticket 159 oh my god american air is
220 now they'll save 80 dollars but then
you're going to take the cab to the
[ __ ] airplane and they try to take
the cash exactly
then you get on the train and they could
upgrade you the upgrade cost oh you want
to sit with six people you don't know or
you can sit in the chairpoint [ __ ]
north looking at a tv that but even
that's first class there's not even good
anymore what the plane yeah when they
upgrade you're like this ain't [ __ ]
luxurious this ain't this is what like
regular flying used to be united charges
for tv
just charged for tv yeah jen blue gives
it to free but now they're charging for
bags oh well yeah well most places give
it to you for free but then united
canceled me out of vermont i have to
drive i had to miss my friend's wedding
and drive to albany to get back here
they should pay you for that i have to
pay more to my rental company they
should pay for all that [ __ ] and pay you
for your trouble the rental company
wouldn't like why couldn't you just drop
off they charge you at everything if you
say oh i can't make that flat i gotta go
later go well we gotta make a change of
change change of ticket fee 75 150 i got
that travel insurance once last year did
it work no hot it was snowing in that
huge door that was that huge storm that
hit new york do you remember you were
calling me oh my god a humongous storm
hit new york so we left an expensive
hotel and paid a bunch of money i bought
a bus ticket and a train ticket and we
got on the last train out of new york
and i called the uh insurance thing i'm
like oh look at it it's not for
weather it's for
some of course something that never
happens
your mom has to get cancer or something
i don't know something's stupid but oh
it doesn't cover weather i don't think
so
it should be for anything i think i
think it was like 25 bucks yeah but
you're never gonna use it it's like
insurance at the blackjack table it's a
shitty bet yeah only suckers get that
[ __ ] suckers and asians
i'm telling you man that's [ __ ]
ridiculous you can't even use your
insurance you're selling that no one
full well you're not getting the car
companies too 25 bucks a day my car i
wait for the best deal for 19.99 then
you're gonna hit me with 25 a day for
insurance
my car insurance just went down from 300
a month to 150 because i had my old
apartment three people ran into my car
yeah i was paying 300 a month for like
three years
three hundred a month for you for me
we'll not even have it i know you may as
well not even have it i'm paying 300 a
month right now for health insurance we
used to get free insurance joe ideas if
he made 13 000
we would get no and we wouldn't have to
pay a dime
we wouldn't have to pay a dime when we
got there was no copay we got to the
doctor everything was free if we made 13
000 are you just laughing because now
you have to make 35 000
and you got to pay [ __ ] uh
hundreds of dollars a month and then
co-pays and it's getting more and more
expensive my girlfriend just went and
they were saying oh glass everybody has
it now
but they won't change the [ __ ] how is
that legal how's that is that legal
i just record your guns
and i need him so soon i'm telling you
that they'll be honest before you know
it i just went with paula to get a
prescription they wanted to charge her
nine hundred dollars
for one prescription
nine hundred dollars she have insurance
she does what it was 900 because it was
like it was it was like cosmetics
why is this more expensive than it was
last time oh the new rules flipped
around we sent you we sent you notice in
the mail so yeah what are you talking
about three of them it's just legal you
have insurance and you're still paying
you have insurance that means you don't
pay anything that's what insurance means
the new insurance is expensive and the
[ __ ] up thing is a lot of places don't
take it because apparently all new
insurance now give it to him all
insurance now is under obamacare and a
lot of those people don't want to take
it no sorry we can't give you mental
health anymore no i know you were
suicidally depressed six months ago we
can't give you a mental health anymore
because the rules changing around we
have to offer to everybody it's not cost
effective so sorry what about those less
insurance what about insurance people
who have to deny people getting paid for
their cancer treatment obamacare and
then knowing they die wait for jared
lochner to go into your offices and see
what happens oh my god what did we go
wrong today
this was a nice american show
please pay 300 love for sure believe in
america there's going to be so many
angry comments on this video
we're going to have like a whole bunch
of arabic comments
we believe the avatars of the
palestinian flag
oh my gosh listen to me i am so [ __ ]
stoked right now
america you wouldn't be billionaire they
keep building you always gonna step in
these [ __ ] stars ain't bad you know
what i'm saying stars are good you're
right
cool high
yeah
how are you doing what do you think i'm
trying right now what are you gonna go
eat
nothing i ate before this because i know
it's gonna be really high and it kind of
helped but you didn't go to the gym
tonight not yet
i go every day do you really yeah i've
lost 81 pounds let's go with me let me
go with you later small lot flying huh
let's go after this
i can't go like this why not you can go
for hours like that oh no no no i i i i
tried doing it once and i almost fell
let's go
let's take an aria tape you will be your
guest today we'll play the feet oh no no
we'll go with the tape and put it on
youtube for the [ __ ] beautiful people
at home
i tell you people happy martin luther
king day martin luther king day the [ __ ]
happened nobody even mentioned black
people
yeah espn was kind of [ __ ] up they
have a martin luther king day game and
it's atlanta versus detroit
they likely they were like selling it as
a special game what do you mean
a martin luther king day back like nba
game
we want to sell this nobody's working
you know black people ain't working but
why did you pick like the two blackest
cities so what who gives a [ __ ] do you
look at it that way i know right
nobody's working people have the day off
they want to watch a martin luther king
basketball game
[ __ ] basketball they have a dream too
they'll probably watch it that's
important going to probably do a special
thing for martin luther king the king
everybody he died for our sins he walked
that's a bad [ __ ] right there
somebody shot him
god blesses you yeah
all right so this week you hope that
next week get the death the comedy works
david county works with mr steve simone
oh [ __ ] he's okay yeah that's a great
show that's how we do it yeah
i'm excited about that you know skiing
before breckenridge
[ __ ] slope it up
i have buffalo new york this thursday
friday and saying oh so cold who's
better than me oh the why that's so cold
i guess timer will be cold too
i'm connecting flights but i don't give
a [ __ ] jack i'm going you don't get
nervous
are you back seattle too i'm in seattle
in february did you get what are we how
are we standing on that i spoke to i
have the celebrate about two hours ago
and i called him back yeah i got his
machines i got a call back
we got to go from square one the the
judge wants me to go back in front of
i'm gonna have to go back and forth and
judge you
can they lock you up can they go lock it
like they thought you know throw the
gauntlet down whatever
they want
and i'm saying right there like take you
into custody but wait joey that'd be
like the number one podcast oh my god
have you got all these
microphones all over
if i didn't watch if you called into the
podcast from president face your charges
when you quit running from the law i
don't want number one podcast to be in
jail i just want to be able to come here
two days a week and do my [ __ ]
podcast is it worth it believe in
america how long ago was it 20 years 20
something what about come on man they
don't give a [ __ ] that makes money
that's why it takes months for trials to
have all the money like they're all
money we just want to live our lives
it's all money we're just trying to live
our lives then aaron hernandez trial is
just about to happen it happened two
years ago yeah and you're just going
just wasting money you punch in five
days a week you know what you cost the
state to keep the state gets a certain
amount of money for every day that
aaron's in jail
the state gets like 55 dollars a day
it's amazing and i know he's guilty and
the prisons are private so they get
money so they want you to stay in jail
longer i know he's guilty but what about
the people who might not be guilty and
just don't have bail money and then have
spent two years in jail for something
they are innocent of that's a great
point that's terrible an excellent point
well what are you gonna do voting
doesn't seem to work it doesn't people
get mad at me when i say don't vote i
mean it doesn't work what's the point
you keep playing their sucker game i
think it's better than doing nothing but
it's like it's not better it's equal to
doing nothing you want to listen in fact
it's probably worse
i just don't get why it's not a popular
vote that's that where it ends for me
yeah just everybody yeah parliament
system what's up buddy no i'm just
checking up on you making sure you're
still black and beautiful always i got
some heavy duty clothing for buffalo
i'll be excited to get some wings with
blue cheese nice excellent
what's up what's the good place down
like the anchor or something no that's
the first place that's that's just like
the tourist oh okay i got some places
that i'm gonna bang out people will take
me i think i'm gonna roll on saturday i
think
that's good yeah
a little bit come back sunday morning
i'm ready to rock are you
what are the questions what is the ten
commandments the questions is [ __ ]
cocksuckerini
you looking goodly
well you should be able to get my
special if you missed it you can buy it
online you can still buy it that's how
we did it yeah like i got cables how was
the process for real it was two seconds
great
yeah you got bonus features right
you got two bunch of teachers it was a
little hard to figure out where i was
going to download it from but i found it
okay but i was all uh i was pretty high
when i when i bought it what was the
dump what was the bonus feature a little
tour of the commerce store like me of
all the [ __ ] i've done around the place
like this is the phone room i would
sleep here that's pretty cool they would
show up yeah and then the june a we did
that joe and a
be embarrassing all the comics do
we get out of that we did it right after
the show did you did your previous show
ended um
i don't know i don't know i would hope
not
yeah we just as soon as this last show
ended we were like that was like thank
you very much everybody's clapping and
then don's just come you can hear what
the brain is going sit down sit down
did you tell this guy
crowd that you were a jew
did they know
and did that happen uh organically like
before not on the special but over time
yeah and then people just start asking
[ __ ] ridiculous questions it's great
yeah i'm happy with it
and 30 more
yes go to ari shafir if you want to get
it and it's on demand too the broadcast
version's on demand but it's like seven
it's like double the time for five
dollars
yeah because the tv version was how long
442
and this was like 72 73 yeah and then
all that extra [ __ ]
what did they take out
a few bits okay a nice public service
announcement
they should watch with your girlfriends
and um
couple fun bits that's cool yeah we just
we didn't really chop the bits up much
we just took out entire bits that is one
of the cool things that corporations do
like how comedy central is now selling
for five dollars because a couple other
comedians made them for five yeah they
like learn learn from the [ __ ] market
some of them sometimes they learn yeah
sometimes they learn you know you can
pay by credit card in a cab now because
uber is like they hate it yeah but it's
like they fight i used to have them go
no i'll drive into an atm cam driving no
i don't have a cash i'll drive through
atm i'm like no dude i'm already where
i'm going
no no no you can't like it's like the
machine's broken and i swipe it and it
works and they're like oh i guess it
works they're [ __ ] [ __ ]
but then they try to they try to get the
law to shut uber down but then it's
because they can [ __ ] their shitty
shitty business and still shove it in
our faces i think it's because like the
taxi companies take money out of their
thing for the credit card transaction so
everyone's getting everything every
credit card started actions take they
charge like 1.7 their credit cards
charge people to use it they get
interest when we don't pay it and they
charge the [ __ ] company to have to
use it
and they'll never go to jail for [ __ ]
there's always a bunch all those bankers
are fine now living in their mansions
what do you think i'm telling you about
him everything there is always a [ __ ]
by the way whether it's a goddamn cab
because the last two times i've gotten
into cities they've asked me are you
paying cash oh yeah and they asked you
up front listen what would you rather
have cash or your card absolutely they
lose a 1.5 percent plus there's a record
of the transaction yeah but then i can
subduct it if i can if i can credit i
can deduct it for my taxes you know
these [ __ ] cab drivers have taken a
tremendous hit with looper they should
they were offering a shitty service
every [ __ ] time you go to an airport
now there's a million cows you go to
vegas maybe vegas you gotta wait a
little bit so many cabs now now you
don't wait you that thing is moving yeah
we change the walk
by the time you get to that first
sidewalk right there where the cabs are
there's a cab waiting for you there's no
more like hold on five seconds yeah wait
no uber just got to las vegas they've
fought him for a while he bought him
they tried to go through the government
they tried to like we can get to the
government because that's the best place
for it because those stupid camp lines
in vegas they just pick you right up
they say oh well no you can't do it from
the airport because because what
get out of here cap companies we don't
want you anymore you can't call an uber
here at the airport you can't
no no you got to go off you can get
dropped you can get dropped off
you dropped off there but you can't call
it two there so yeah that's a trick
somebody said that you could take a
shuttle to one of the yeah you can do
that but then just extra time but like
why why can't you get picked up you can
get picked up from your friend because
the taxi companies paid people they pay
people off that's no reason you
shouldn't be able to do it that's called
lobbying
this is not usually a political podcast
and you just pay less money for a better
oh it's clean all the time
oh you refuse to make your [ __ ] clean
and you're charging twice as much what
why
tell me why and they're not using child
labor
so why shouldn't we i don't understand
why shouldn't we go over there and use
their thing no no no they're not
accredited accredited what you guys are
terrible drivers cab drivers are
horrible it's super dangerous every time
you get in it's less expensive it cost
me 12 to get from laurel canyon right
here down to the improv tip you don't
want to talk to him just do your [ __ ]
where's this blitz just [ __ ] enter it
man in your favor
you can you can extra if you want oh
it's already in there but it's in there
the original it goes to them it goes to
them they takes their money they pay him
for their miles and here's their money
people make their money apparently
that's why they do it because they make
good money tons of people it's all these
ex-cab drivers too yeah fine well it's
it's also limo drivers but then they get
the actual they get the money now yeah
they get the money yeah why do you go to
your boss now i can just work for myself
no one should be unemployed if you have
a car exactly why should you if you want
to use what you have to make money and
here's the deal if you're a bad driver
you get bad reviews then they say we
don't watch you anymore
then they're like you're no longer an
uber driver you guys review every driver
uh-huh i try to i mean because before
they bring up the next one when you try
to order the next one they go what'd you
think of this guy for the last one so
then you go right there you're like oh
oh that was terrible but they didn't
deal with me last time they emailed this
to me i hit the wrong store i thought i
was just clicking on something to go to
where i would rate them yeah and i
clicked on the fourth star by mistake
and i think i went back and tried to
give him a five but usually it's five if
they've like shitty seats you're like
four i haven't even told joey i'm not
sure if i'm gonna do it but i have some
free time i thought about i looked into
becoming an uber driver yeah why not i
went down there today comics do a lot of
comments to it yeah they always have a
nice car there's a line down there today
a line to get in
to where to be an uber driver i went i
just i looked online i was like i don't
know if i'm going to do this or not but
i was someone told me they made a bunch
of money
so i i went down it was a parking lot in
west l.a
and every 30 seconds three new cars went
and they had five people doing
inspections really making sure you're
making sure you're blind
well they have that
yeah but uh they were making sure the
blinkers and the horn worked and you had
seat belts and then
you went and then they gave you uh
because they get they give you a
background check but they went and they
give you
some uber stuff and
i i don't know i might do it if i have
some free time why not make a couple
hundred bucks and people like it's
dangerous you don't know who you're
getting your cod with it and you're like
yes you do know because you ordered it
through the [ __ ] device it keeps a
record of that you don't know with cavs
yes i don't know if you lose something
you can tell i know what it was you can
contact someone
i gotta be so [ __ ] bad
you wanna go
yeah something [ __ ] i'm dancing here oh
i thought you were dancing to be
advanced yeah i mean obviously the
rhythm is in my heart and stuff but
it got me for sure
he was going to get me and then it got
me it's up to the left
i'll be right back
he's [ __ ] thugs i love it i didn't
know you had to pee we're getting [ __ ]
yeah i know let's do the sponsors right
now just in case let's give a shout out
to the main people that keep this show
[ __ ] rocking them on it
there's not much i could say about these
savages i just went on my alpha brain
[ __ ] uh regimen last week i had great
sets this week i slept great i had some
lucid dreams but you know when i feel
good i feel energetic alpha brain is
their flagship [ __ ] the pork
fried rice of this whole operation if
you ain't [ __ ] around with uh alfred
brandon you're messing around with honor
you're [ __ ] slipping go to honor.com
right now see what they got available to
you i'm not bullshitting you from the
strong bone i give you the same [ __ ]
[ __ ] every week and you sit there
you listen to me what the [ __ ] is wrong
with you go down right now right now get
the alpha break you don't like it it's
100 money back guarantee you don't lose
your guts you don't even have to send it
back that's how [ __ ] much confident
they are about their product but then
they don't stop there whether it's the
shroom tech whether it's the [ __ ] new
boot whether it's the 180 turnaround
whether whether it's the mct oil out of
this does not stop go to honda.com right
now press in church and get 10 off look
at the stay on a program where they send
everything directly to your home all
right go to honda.com right now start
right now forget the resolution also my
main man dave foley
over at iron dragon [ __ ] tv
the best in classic martial art films 4k
tv it's a roku channel and that's what
they specialize in they add new movies
every week whether you like uh the
movies that uh what's his name did over
in china jackie chan jackie chan today
man series i mean i'll tell you every
week do me a favor go there stop [ __ ]
around that's right
tv.com we're gonna give you two movies
on the arm for [ __ ] free just to go
over them they got a ton of other stuff
they got joe rogan training they got a
lot of videos punches on it videos go
over there right now you get two free
movies for free tell them uncle joey
sent you we ain't [ __ ] with you go to
iron dragon tv right now if you don't
like classic martial arts you're
thinking about getting this ufc started
somebody was scratching their head no
because they watched two chinese guys
flying in the [ __ ] air with strings
and they said maybe we get a fat [ __ ]
skinny [ __ ] to do this
go to [ __ ] iron irondragontv.com
right now press in chilly ooh get two
free [ __ ] movies on the uh tell about
that joey sent you also by maybe over at
anything.com throwing heat with the
[ __ ] vapor cigar whether you want the
cigarettes whether you quit real
cigarettes and you want the [ __ ] hit
e-cigarettes they're the best on the
market guaranteed 1200 pops per [ __ ]
machine here this is a [ __ ] machine
check it
out been smoking the same [ __ ] thing
for three weeks you understand me go to
86.com right now and press it yeah he's
just get 20 off your orders get sent
right to your [ __ ] house you're gonna
leave the house you order it today
you'll get like by thursday or friday
and let's give a big shout out to my
main [ __ ] over there nailed it
life.com specializing in the vapor pen
for all you [ __ ] dabbers and waxes
and whatever the [ __ ] are
you want to blow yourself up with some
real wax go to nails in life they got
what you need they got the blow torch
the little blow torch the long spoon to
stick the [ __ ] thing in the cannon
you'll be smoking for weeks go to it
naileganlive.com
their specialty vapor paint right now
they're gonna give you twenty percent
off you understand me go to the box and
press it joey the end oh [ __ ] who's
better than you you got yourself a vapor
pen you got yourself a hidden sig you
got two free movies and you got vitamins
to keep you out that's how we roll here
at the church what's happening now
[ __ ] get it together sleeping
while you're creeping hey what do you
think of um jose elder fighting that
that kid i think jose aldo's gonna
[ __ ] take him and break him in
[ __ ] halfway you don't like conor
mcgregor
listen it's just uh it's just a role
that's not level guys yet though just a
rolled up uh he's very good at what he
does but he's just a rolled up channel
senate
and every time they get in bed with
these guys thank god dana has a little
dignity he's gonna have the fight in las
vegas
instead of in brazil
home court right you know that's enough
of that either this is about jose aldo
he's the champion it's his [ __ ] call
but they want to put him in an arena but
he told me months ago that sieber wasn't
going to be any sort of opponent no yeah
so then it's like now he suddenly
deserves it after fighting a number 10
guy it's like come on he lost his
paperwork another trip from germany that
guy they love him though people love him
oh delicious no that'll be gregor well
kind of people love cosby too you know
what are you telling me he just keeps
roundhouse kicking over and over again
he's very pushing he's very what's he
like in the ground he's 26 that's what
we'll see we don't really know huh
nobody knows if you watch any of you
nine tkos i mean i guess some of them
were from getting on top and stuff and
working position his [ __ ] leg kicks
jose out they'll come at you like this
is so good listen if conor mcgregor is
not in the gym today start the training
for what the wrath he's gonna go into
he's also pulling that channel center
where he's picking that to be
that was wwe he knew he was going to do
that you know why he was going to do
that because dana's bodyguard was there
waiting for him
they knew that was wwe [ __ ] if you're at
home gold khan is so cool that was all
planned oh yeah yeah was it do you think
it was planned do you think it was yeah
it wasn't planned in jose aldo's world
cup i don't think jose looked surprised
like he stood up because i'm not going
to just say he went there but he didn't
really want to go laugh it off but
uh the other guy went there but he
didn't really want to go there so you
[ __ ] jumped down he was just loud but
he wasn't gonna get yeah for you
gentiles that got impressed he went for
it but he made sure there was ten people
there before he got there yeah like he
stopped he jumped over the table stopped
on the table and waited for people to go
yeah then he stepped down he stepped in
so a few people who were impressed and
jumping up and down
you get you people were [ __ ]
overtaken too quickly i could sell you a
[ __ ] bridge you [ __ ] idiots what
do you think about and here's why elsa
was playing why was jose elder there
they don't they don't come to all the
ones well that's why they're all away
from brazil from rio de janeiro from
boston he's drinking coconut juice and
getting this they haven't come to
certain ones especially if it's like a
new it's the same weight class well yeah
they always do that that's the next
fight but yeah
jose albus
give a [ __ ] you know now the most
interesting thing i like to leave joe
rogan kept saying to him jose aldo are
you ready to make more money now that
you're gonna find an arena and dana was
like why is he saying that [ __ ] no just
because we're fighting arena don't get
me and he's getting more money that
means we'll get more [ __ ] paper you
know what i'm saying wait he fought an
arena in brazil didn't he was it
chicken's cheap or something i don't
know
that place went crazy did you go to that
one the one where he jumped into the
stands yeah then he jumped right by me
oh my god dude he he jumped off he he
wins they don't even wait till i [ __ ]
interview him or anything [ __ ] jumps
out runs and hugs the [ __ ]
broadcasters that he knows the brazilian
and then runs into the stands starts
hugging all his friends and family and
[ __ ]
his yardies
that was so i was [ __ ] crying wasn't
even high
we didn't even get we till later
i was crying was so nice it was such a
magical moment that place was going
crazy
i don't know the only other time it was
going that crazy was were you in
columbus when
when randy beat tim sylvia yeah oh that
was like a
that from the first fight of the first
night the very first friday night the
place was packed it was like it was
always a good fight place i don't know
what happened i was there with anderson
for
rich franklin oh yeah that's the one we
went to the club for the bodybuilding
thing yeah it's the arnold classic so
while the ufc is a town all these big
bodybuilders are walking around because
the but it's an arnold classic i'll be
around classic that's right i'll be
there this year
yeah i'll be in there soon all weekend
columbus oh that's cool i'm really
[ __ ] excited i've been there two
years you know the first time i went
there but to the funny bone to the funny
bone in columbus the first time i went
there was adjusted
it was uh so last year was 2014. so this
was 2013.
i think mercy was just born it was the
first week of the road
after being home for eight weeks and
nine weeks without the comedy store i
had like the haha and i had like
flappers you know like [ __ ] like that
you know i went to columbus guys i gotta
tell you something i hate it
five [ __ ] shows just
bomb really oh
i got labs but you know those labs you
get anywhere
it was those laughs where it was nothing
put together like i got shot from doing
15 minutes at flappers
to 47 and 48 minutes at
columbus thursday i remember doing okay
but friday and saturday i just died of
slow debt didn't bring me back last year
oh really but they renovated the place
but i didn't do that well in columbus so
i called him back and told him the truth
and he [ __ ] brought me back he goes
no i thought that you know you set with
a little rusty you could tell
and that's why lee we worked hard this
[ __ ] off season because you gotta i
was home for a few weeks you know i did
that show in vegas for you but 45 you
got to get warmed up yeah you got to get
warmed up so i've been warming up the
last couple weeks it's been fun at the
comedy store lately really
it's uh
it's bringing me back you know for
people it's great to be up there there's
a certain freedom at the comedy store
you can go off you can do whatever the
[ __ ] you want and it's it's here's how
it is let's say you go to the ymca every
day yeah and you go to harry's house and
you lift weights
and every day you lift way to the rear
of the ymca you push about
two and a quarter
four cents a ten
for some reason when you go to the
comedy store
you could push 265. yeah it's one of
those kind of gyms it's one of those
type of places i used to i used to not
like 15-minute sets as a as a
viewer too short yeah because i used to
like longer i used to real only prefer
like the hour-long sets yeah and they
all went to sevens and eights but then
going with joey to the comments for the
last few months
it's crazy to see how how good he's
gotten but then when you're when you're
really good and anybody who's really
good it's crazy to like be a part like
you i don't think you could hold that
for 15 for like 60 minutes but for 15
minutes you could like what's a
different
yeah it's a different
sprint i know i got 18 minutes i know i
could condense
32 minutes into 18 minutes which means
danger and just killing them yeah you're
just gonna have little sentences out at
them and they're gonna suck each one up
but there's no setup there's no pla you
know i can eliminate everything i'll
eliminate the segway if you left me i'll
just say blood slice like a [ __ ]
and say it my way you know because as a
consumer
maya asuka
this is a special podcast you got a fur
a fart and a bird
you got a fart and a burp in this one
we got to get the [ __ ] out of here guys
ari shafir so you're at the denver
comedy works next week
and then where else in february the
parliament the new downtown parliament
is seattle where around seattle
braya portland
so you're in portland in february
i think on march where are you in
february [ __ ] parlor and bryant
two weeks
two weeks yeah where are you the next
two weeks oh denver all right this
weekend super bowl super bowl week
goodbye weekend then uh two weeks after
that seattle okay i think that might be
until the very end of february yeah
you're like me you're just going out
very limited yeah it's the time you're
here yeah we're trying to make put it
together right here during pilot season
yeah portland bray is like in townish
you know brae is good might go to san
diego maybe i don't know
we'll figure it out and get back to us
i love you [ __ ] i'm going to be
in buffalo this weekend
and uh
next week i'll be at the columbus
[ __ ] funny bone and that's it
guys thank you very much happy mom
luther king day to all the black people
out there we gotta end this with some
[ __ ] black music yeah
what do you think guys
sam cook
let's do something let's do a little
michael jackson oh yeah remember the
time michael jackson in honor of being
over over overcome by bill cosby on the
we don't want to believe it thor
thank you i for coming on tonight yeah
man this is a lot of fun those guys are
great all your success i'm telling you
thanks we watched at the comedy store
everybody's in the patty of the
conversation yeah i went on the way up i
just couldn't get in there so i just
yeah i got it at the house me and the
wife watched it last night for a little
while we i loved the piano thing i
really [ __ ] around jeff that's what i
wanted to show just like a regular set
at the end
i [ __ ] around the crowd a little and
you know
yeah the stuff with jeff was it cool
seeing it on the tv on tv like seeing
your name on tv guy that has to be kind
of cool that was all right that was okay
i like seeing that store watching like
on the on the [ __ ] you know like you
don't you don't have a dvr same room
yeah i don't have a dvr if i went to my
dvr i got it on my dvr it looks very
nice yeah but if you had like the joey
ds special and you're just scrolling
through and it's next like that'd be
kind of cool maybe that's right right
right your own thing
all right close this show cox what are
we closing with oh yeah okay
that was a catch dez bryant that was a
catch
i think so too
everybody knows that was a catch great
seattle game though
let's be honest that was classic
okay enjoy your show i'm sorry
go to honor.com and use cowork church to
get 10 off of your order
uh go to hit e6.com better tasting
longer lasting the proof
is in the vape uh use cardboard joey's
turn to get twenty percent off
go to iron dragon tv and you go where
joey get two free rentals [ __ ] up yeah
and gonna nail this live.com
you guys are crazy